and the Philadelphia Inquirer says
surveillance video was shown in court of
a Penn State frat party before a pledged
ID
Timothy Piazza died in February after a
hazing ritual at the Beta Theta Pi house
a teen returned eighty brothers are
waiting to find out if they will stand
trial defense attorneys will
cross-examine witnesses at a later date
DeMarco Morgan is in Bellefonte
Pennsylvania he was in the courtroom
when the footage was shown publicly for
the first time DeMarco good morning good
morning Nora prosecutors played about
three hours of video and the scenes that
were captured by the fraternity's own
surveillance cameras were chilling they
not only show Timothy Piazza and hours
of agony but what prosecutors would
describe as his would-be brother's
callousness to his suffering what was
supposed to be Timothy Piazza's first
night in this fraternity house as a Beta
Theta Pi brother ended up being his last
12 security cameras captured the Penn
State sophomore slowly dying from his
injuries to his head and spleen
sustained - during this series of Falls
is it a bombshell
it's a bombshell yeah prosecutor Stacey
parks Miller sent an act of hazing left
the 19 year old with a blood-alcohol
content
nearly four times the legal driving
limit a video shows a barbaric death a
young man who was struggling he was sick
who was ill who was in pain Piazza fell
down the basement stairs
shortly before 11:30 p.m. fraternity
brothers found Piazza bruised and
unconscious
video shows him hitting him or point
liquid on his face in an apparent effort
to revive him others were seen propping
Piazza up with a backpack or sitting on
his legs the video speaks volumes
in regard to my client's innocence
attorney William Brennan represents
Joseph M's whom the grand jury said
struck Piazza in the abdomen while he
was unconscious the video I saw fuzzy as
it is Joey may have reached down to
arouse him but he certainly didn't punch
him and it's as a concern you that Joey
didn't call for help didn't call that
charged with that it concerns me that no
one called for help until 11 o'clock the
next day Piazza was largely left alone
during the early morning hours and the
footage he staggers collapses and slams
his head at times he arrives on the
floor in obvious distress he apparently
fell down the basement stairs a second
time and by the time Piazza was found
hours later a detective who watched the
video said he looked like a corpse
Piazza's family left at the courtroom
before the videos were played Tom Klein
is the family's attorney the videotape
was simply stated too painful for the
Piazza's to watch they said that they
just couldn't do it at least not in hell
prosecutors obtained about 13 hours of
security footage the judge has yet to
set a new hearing date but the
fraternity which is also a defendant in
the case told CBS this morning
it has confidence in the judicial system
that due process and justice can and
will be served back to you the question
that continues to haunt is why why
that's why it's so hard to hear the more
details you hear because you keep
learning that it really did not have to
happen or go down this way that's why
it's so heartbreaking thanks for that
report DeMarco